the S Club 7 Star Paul catamole has died
at the age of 46. the band set manager
has said there's no suspicious
circumstances and the band has released
quite a long tribute message on Twitter
that says we are utterly we are truly
devastated by the passing of our brother
Paul there are no words to describe the
deep sadness and loss we all feel we
were so lucky to have had him in our
lives and are thankful for the amazing
memories uh we have this does of course
come fairly soon after the February
announcement that the band would go on
tour again with 11 dates in the UK and
Ireland for their 25th anniversary and
just adds of course to the sadness and
surprise at his passing a bit more of
that statement from the band saying he
will be so deeply missed by each and
every one of us we ask that you respect
the privacy of his family and of the
band at this time so very sad news the
uh singer the star Paul catamole of S
Club 7 has died at the age of 46 passing
away just a month or so after the band
announced plans to reform for 11 UK and
Ireland dates to celebrate the band's
25th anniversary